hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
tech channel of the week episode now I
know I haven't made a tech channel of
the week episode in a good month or so
and it kind of makes me mad that I
wasn't able to do those but as you guys
know I have been uploading videos a
little bit less frequently so I plan on
doing to check tech channel of the week
episodes per month from now on so to
texture not Louie episodes per month and
I couldn't resist putting down this
series because there's so many great
channels that I love to spotlight and
get you guys some attention so anyway
let's just get right onto this guys so I
picked the channel to revive the tech
channel of the week series on and I'll
be uploading this of course on a weekend
but I'm just going to go ahead and show
you guys this channel right now this
channel is called I bellick's David Bell
and his channel obviously his link will
be in the description so you guys can
check that out youtube.com slash I
bellick's and as we scroll down here
basically since he is the tech channel
of the week I'm gonna give you guys a
quick tour of his YouTube channel and
hopefully you guys will check it out so
first of all on the left hand side
you'll see he has two thousand five
hundred seventy one channel views he
joined in April 2009 not too long ago so
actually it's a relatively new channel
he's watched more than nine-thousand
nine-hundred videos and he has just won
him he has just over 130 he has a
hundred and thirty six subscribers so if
you guys want to go ahead and support
him and help him out right now we can
push him over 200 guys I know you guys
can do that so guys if we scroll down
here he actually does have a website the
David Bell and if you go ahead and open
it in a new tab
I'll go ahead and throw this in the
description if you guys want to check it
out it looks fairly new to me obviously
his whole YouTube thing and the online
thing is new so everything is just
getting a fresh start and that's pretty
cool
as we scroll down a little bit there's
all his channel comments some scroll
down even more he has some honors so
number 66 most of you today reporters in
Canada number 98 most viewed this month
reporters in Canada so that is awesome
so I'm gonna scroll back up here because
this at the top is actually I guess the
most interesting part of a person
channel he has 46 video uploads and his
latest video was actually a tour of a
geeks room so you guys can go ahead and
look at his setup and all that cool
stuff so if we go ahead and look at all
video uploads you guys can see that this
channel is actually just like mine a mix
of hardware and software videos so there
was recently an unboxing of a 23 inch LG
monitor I'm actually in the market for a
larger monitor right now I'm I think
I've made up my mind on a 20 inch LG but
this this unboxing video was definitely
helpful in terms of choosing what I
exactly I wanted to do so several
unboxing several reviews there's
recently an iTunes gift card giveaway so
if you guys want to be included in those
types of things on this channel
definitely go check it out and obviously
like I said a lot more tutorials so if
we go ahead and I actually my favorite
part of this channel is the playlist if
you go over to the playlist section on
my youtube 2.0 layout and unexpanded you
can see all 6 unboxing videos has done
iPod Nano 4G more than one monitor
unboxing and his awesome
Samsung 3 at Co 3u microphone unboxing
great microphone so if you guys couldn't
already tell by the microphone is using
this is great quality videos um the
channel it really puts out great quality
videos and there is no no concern of
quantity on this channel it's all about
quality of Facebook versus Twitter video
an application review so guys like I
said if you want to check out I
bellick's that link will be in the
description as long as his um as well as
his website link and that is basically
it so thank you for watching this tech
channel of the week episode if you want
to be included in the search for a new
tech channel of the week every two weeks
just go ahead and leave a comment make
sure you you get yourself noticed just
let me know what kind of tech videos you
do you do that mostly Hardware mostly
software you know let me get a good idea
anyway thank you for watching this tech
channel of the week episode I hope you
guys go check out I bellick's in the
description and that is basically it
thank you for watching guys peace
you